frequent sex is the greatest glue of
relationships it's pretty rare for
anyone to leave anyone with whom they
have regular satisfying sex but sadly
there are so many things that get in the
way of sex hidden resentments and also
shyness it can be hard to know if
they're in the mood and how horrible to
feel one might be bugging them into
doing something they don't want and then
sometimes you're not too sure you're in
the mood you sort of wanted but it can
be hard to snap out of more practical
working state of mind all of which is
what makes the attitude to sex found in
Orthodox Judaism very useful indeed in
the Torah the Jewish holy book of laws
and rules of conduct the ancient rabbis
categorically state that it's God's will
that a husband and wife have sex every
Friday night at the beginning of a
Shabbat holiday it doesn't matter if
he's not quite in the mood or she's not
entirely sure God wants you to do this
thing and that's the end of the story
this is genius because it immediately
cuts through all the destructive
self-conscious reasons why people don't
have regular sex and thereby ruin
perfectly good relationships the
god-given nature of the command shifts
the rationale for having sex away from
the individuals involved they no longer
have to agonize about how they feel and
it places the responsibility with an
abstract divine entity who just can't be
disobeyed you don't have to shyly say
you in the mood and deal with all the
possible reasons why they might not be
you both know you just have to head on
with it the good news is we don't
actually have to be Jewish or even
religious to benefit from this wisdom we
too can make rules sex once a week
probably on a Friday not because you
want to or I want to necessarily but
because that's the rule no ifs ands or
buts waiting for the desire to have sex
is a dangerous romantic Lynn we may have
to wait so long and end up having so
little sex the relationship collapses
don't wait to have sex until you want to
make it something you have to do if for
nothing else to keep God that imaginary
sex therapist in the sky happen if you
like our films take a look at our shop
the School of Life comm forward slash
shop you'll find lots of thoughtful
books games stationery and more
you